panic spread on the strip last night  after reports of shots fired near mgm  grand began to circulate thankfully it  was just a false alarm metro police say  someone broke a glass window at the  valley parking of the mgm grand causing  hundreds to run away because it sounded  like a gunshot officers say no one was  ever in any danger  we are one of the safest communities  america we have a very robust response  especially in our las vegas strip we  have an officer at every single  intersection and and every single  pedestrian bridge that's why we were  able to quickly respond and determine  that there was no shooting that occurred  players at the world series of poker  going on at valleys were told to clear  the area before the threat was found on  metro says other reports of shootings at  the other strip properties were likely  caused by the panic from the mgm  incident